making reportedly slow progress on major
fronts russia has widened its war on
ukraine
the missiles that fell on a military
training center near javorev in the far
west killed dozens soldiers and cadets
that russia claims were foreign trained
fighters preparing to enter the war
just a few months ago joint military
exercises took place here ukrainian
troops alongside allies from 14
countries yet now they're having to
fight and die in this war largely alone
scores more were injured in the most
devastating single attack so far and
with worrying implications for supply
routes delivering humanitarian and
military aid
the war has now come to western ukraine
and with it a sense that perhaps nowhere
in this country is safe
but of larger significance is the fact
that not just the country's main supply
routes are now vulnerable not just the
main avenues of escape for hundreds of
thousands of refugees have now become
vulnerable but the fact that the war has
now come
within 20 kilometers or so
of a nato border
in javorev on sunday morning anna woke
to the sound of explosions
i thought someone was breaking into the
house we went outside and the whole sky
was red
we met anna at a fuel stop a pregnant
daughter a niece and her grandchild in
the car making a dash for the polish
border
at home my sick father a husband and a
brother-in-law stayed behind
i would pick up arm myself and fight but
we have to save our children
and once again calls for nato to
intervene to enforce a no-fly zone over
ukraine
rockets have fallen 10 kilometers from
the border with europe
tomorrow they may fall 10 kilometers on
the other side in poland where our wives
and children are now i call on europe
save yourselves save us because tomorrow
it will be too late
but nato continues to have no appetite
to confront russia directly as the war
grinds on
in cities like cherny heap in the north
steady nerves required here
to remove an unwelcome delivery through
someone's front window
civilians those brave or desperate
enough to attempt escape continue to
leave areas close to kiev like erpin
where an american journalist was killed
when he and a colleague were fired on by
russian forces
and no respite yet again for mariopol
satellite images show swathes of
destruction in the southern city
besieged for two weeks the life being
strangled out of it an aid convoy once
again prevented from entering
there is one constant the inexhaustible
morale boosting russia-defying presence
of a comedian who once played the role
of president on tv now handing out
medals
and giving the performance of his life
jonah al jazeera yavariv